كلاسيك
الانقلابيون يهددون بقتل الرئيس النيجري
محمد بازوم اذا قررت اي دوله للتدخل
عسكريا في البلاد خطوه انقلبت الطاوله على
منظمه التي طرحت خيار تدخل العسكري لردع
الانقلاب فما سيناريوهات التدخل في هذه
الظروف
جماعه حكومه النيجر العناصر الضروريه
للاثباتات لكي تتابع امام الهيئات الوطنيه
والدوليه المؤهله الرئيس المتاح به
وشركائه في الداخل والخارج بتهمتي الخيانه
العظمى والمس بامن النيجر في الداخل
والخارج ثلاث مسارات متوقعه لحل الازمه
على طريقه
[موسيقى]
التدخل العسكري رغم الاخطار قرار المستبعد
لكنه لا يزال قائما بسبب عده عوامل اولها
تضاؤل احتمال تفاعل الانقلابيين مع الحلول
الدبلوماسيه بعد رفضهم دخول ممثلين عن
الاتحاد الافريقي والامم المتحده وخشيه
المنظمه ان تتفكك بعد اخفاقها في اربع
ازمات متلاحقه هي انقلابات النيجر وقبلها
مالي وبوركينا فاسو وغينيا والعامل الاهم
وجود دعم دولي للتدخل العسكري من دول كبرى
لديها قوات في النيجر مثل فرنسا والولايات
المتحده
الضغط الدبلوماسي
قطه تبدا بتمديد المهله الممنوحه
للانقلابيين لتسليم السلطه ودعوه وسطاء
جدد من خارج المنظمه الافريقيه للتدخل
وتهديد المجلس العسكري بحصار اقتصادي
للقبول بتسويه تقوم على تسيير مرحله
انتقاليه وتنظيم انتخابات جديده يتعهد
فيها العسكر بتسليم السلطه الى مجلس مدني
المنتخب لكن هذا الخيار قد يزعزع مصداقيه
المنظمه الافريقيه
الضغط الاقتصادي
خيار اخير بعد اخفاق المسار الثاني تتبناه
ايكواس اذا لم يفي الانقلابيون بعهودهم
وهو ما حدث في حاله مالي عندما نكس المجلس
العسكري عن الاتفاق وتمديد المهله المتفقه
عليها من 18 شهرا الى خمس سنوات حينها
ستتوقف ايكواس عن وسائل التدخل التقليديه
وتكتفي بخيار الضغط الاقتصادي لحصار
الانقلابيين
برايك ما الخيار الاقرب للتطبيق